key cette semaine le magazine des jeunes
va nous conduire en corrèze
oh
e
votez
temps
et que ça sans plus
des enfants
non
vraiment ça nul
pas
à la fois centre culturel à la fois
centre sportif cette maison est ouverte
à tous depuis plus d'un an
je suis à fond tir l'école de formation
de la manufacture normes de tulle vous
voyez qu est ce que vous venez y faire
et au foyer je vais faire la natation on
peut imaginer aussi vous êtes combien de
jeunes à venir dans ce joyeux je crois
qu'il ya un peu plus de 4000 adhérents
qui se répartissent durant toute la
semaine mais les jours d'affluence jeudi
du samedi après midi et le dimanche ben
ali dont il connaît un habitant à tulle
as tu eu le plus de 20000 habitants
seront ça fait pratiquement un cinquième
de voyage au port
un cinquième de la population de kull
dont jeune boîte culte fréquence est
extraordinaire complexe unique dans le
département de la corrèze la piscine
connaître un grand succès d'affluence
originalité du centre on peut y
pratiquer tous les sports dans le même
temps on les cultive les activités
artistiques traditionnelles
je fais du sport l'escrimé la natation
mais je fais gardant la tique aussi
pas mal de choses
c'est quand même temps de votre vie où
vous voyez quelques heures dans la
semaine 4 ou 5 arrêts semaine aux
parents que ce que vous enduire
sont pas très d'accord quelquefois
surtout pour l'art dramatique qui me
prend à 7 ans
enfin maurice colère oui on essaie de
concilier les deux il va sans forme de
presse comme ange avec ses doigts une
valse avec des écailles comme un petit
poisson une valse pour les volailles
pour les saucissons il va sans brader il
il va sort en pâté de foie il va sans
pudeur choix qui va ça
2 crois qu'à
trois cas
car vous vous êtes mariés
depuis deux ans
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
une fille nue
nageuse dans la mer
un homme barbu
marche sur l'eau
où elle à merveille des merveilles
le
miracle annoncé plus haut
je suis né tout nu je vis comme je suis
né je suis né tout petit si j'ai grandi
trop vite jamais je n'ai changé et je
vis tout nu pour la plupart du temps
cette tranche 10 nu ces temps c'est de
l'argent
c'est surtout en fait pour moi une
recherche veut un divertissement une
certaine détente de par mon travail
qu'est ce que vous faites dans la vie je
suis fonctionnaire fausse yeux salariés
et on a quand même besoin de se détendre
et de faire un peu autre chose que peu
la routine administrative et je viens
surtout au point de vue informations je
voudrais y approfondir mes connaissances
comme fils poésie au point de vue là
pour voir les transmettre ensuite à mon
enseignement
en deux mois
dégagé
dans l'ue
toutes les sociétés de la ville qui en
ont exprimé le désir ont trouvé
moyennant une location asile dans ses
locaux parfaitement adapté les parents
également ont pu inscrire leurs enfants
un cours de danse
cette visite rapide à tulle ne nous
permet pas de tout vous montrer on
pratique dans cette maison des dizaines
d'autres activités elles sont dirigées
par de jeunes animateurs qui s'efforcent
d'intéresser les garçons et les filles à
un sport un art
leur idéal que cette maison n'est pas de
cloison mais il ya aussi des jeunes qui
sont réticents vous êtes ici un peu par
hasard vous aujourd'hui vous êtes venu
avec un camarade vous y venez rarement
assez haut
pourquoi c'est parce que je parle ne le
fait pas un intérêt entre particuliers
pap des pays représentant les intérêts
mais pour une vue lecture ou musique à g
skill beau chez moi et puis
je viens paye pour ciné club doit
surtout parce que c'est pas dresser de
films chez moi et pour le reste j'ai
effectivement coûts du personnel je fais
pas de sport l'équipe et
ça va très bien comme ça je peux vous
aimez centre est ce qu'il
ne peut pas
à thouars
plus vite la touche or
j'estime que les jeunes ont quand même
besoin de quelque chose de solide
derrière eux quand on est dans une ville
comme la nôtre ou iard y ait d'abord le
foyer culturel pour nous c'est quelque
chose de chouette parce que ça nous aide
à supporter
les parents l'école et puis à aimer
quelque chose et elle pratique est lent
vous vous aimez le théâtre
répondant que l'impression d'être enfin
j'aime pas le mot mais embrigader ou non
non on est libres latino review cela
envie de ne pas venir suivre une
activité que vous suivez depuis
d'habitude on peut lâcher quand on veut
d'abord ça m'a fait connaître ce que
c'est un bel théâtre parce que j'avais
jamais rien fait ou avec le lycée agents
mais c'était moins bien maintenant on a
quelqu'un qui nous dirigent
c'est différent
qu'est ce que vous faisiez vous le voyez
il existe le passé ses occupations à se
promener en ville quoi sans plus y avait
rien d'attrayant
et depuis la création de ce centre
venir passer des après midi
pas et si les gens
en vain
dimon